[Musique]
regardez un paysage c'est pénétrer dans
un pays c'est découvrir très rapidement
ses produits sur l'architecturé et ces
gens pour bien des français on est ce
qu'on mange
mais on pourrait aussi dire qu'on est le
lieu où on vit
[Musique]
plus mon espace est beau logiquement les
gens qui sont dedans se sentent bien et
c'est le reflet de ce qu'ils sont
la france est une mosaïque culturelle
historique et géographique tout le 6 km
à vous changer de paysage en france puis
un paysage et divers plus il peut
s'adapter à des crises
[Musique]
la france en fait toute l'europe et
beaucoup d'autres pays leur paysage
d'aujourd'hui sont l'héritage
d'activités humaines passées sur un
territoire qui a une histoire géologique
une histoire climatique yves michelin a
fait carrière en étudiant l'histoire
paysagère de france dont celle de sa
région le massif central en plein coeur
du pays
ici on trouve une série de volcans
unique appelé la chaîne des puys
on estime qu'on est les dépositaires
d'un des rares endroits au monde où on
peut comprendre des mécanismes
essentiels de la tectonique qui est la
déchirure d'un continent et on a ici une
collection plus de 80 un volcan
pratiquement toutes les formes
imaginables
on trouve dans le monde entier elles
sont réunis ici
[Musique]
si tout ce paysage des moins d'une
histoire géologique riche et puissante
pour yves michelin il témoigne aussi de
l'évolution de la place qu'occupe
l'humain dans cet espace 200 300 ans
avant jésus-christ ce paysage là il est
déjà agricole la végétation spontanée
ici c'est la forêt s'il n'y a pas de
forêt c'est qu'il ya d'activité humaine
quand on voit de l'herbe ici derrière
l'herbe
il ya des vaches ou des moutons et
derrière les vaches et les moutons il ya
des éleveurs
si on enlève les éleveurs c'est les
arbres qui replace est ce que la chaîne
des puys complètement boisé on le veut
on le veut pas est-ce que localement on
a envie de vivre dans les sapins ou pas
la réponse à ces questions s'est imposée
d'elle-même à bien des endroits en
france
allons voir la vallée de la bruche en
alsace
si cette valley est une région
aujourd'hui bien forestière ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
derrière moi on retrouve une trace du
passé industriel textile en fait c'est
une usine textile tels qu'il en existait
dans tous les villages de la vallée de
la bruche
en gros il y avait 52 sites industriels
textiles sur les 25 communes du
territoire
les gens travaillent à l'usiné et
détenait aussi des terres qu'ils
cultivaient c'était leur mode de vie
on les appelait les ouvriers paysans
c'était une terre nourricière puisque
chacun travaillé dans l'industrie t cm
se nourrissent et des fonds de vallées
pour de l'air pour les vaches les
coteaux pour faire des céréales des
champs de pommes de terre et les
secteurs d'inquiétude pour nourrir les
animaux en peinture en été c'était une
vraie économie locale qui a bien
fonctionné jusqu'en 1950 après guerre et
tout ça a péréclité de fait les ouvriers
ils ont quitté le territoire et ils ont
abandonné leurs terres quoi même s'ils
représentent un faible pourcentage de la
population française
les agriculteurs sont en grande partie
responsables de l'ouverture des paysages
s'il abandonne la terre c'est la friche
qui prend le dessus
mais là où l'agriculture et prospère
c'est un autre phénomène qui se produit
c'est la tendance à l'agrandissement des
parcelles les agriculteurs âgés n'ont
pas de successeur parce que le foncier
est trop cher et donc libère de la terre
qui est racheté par des agriculteurs qui
en ont les moyens et qui a grandi ces
prairies agrandissent les champs et donc
en agrandissant supprime des supprimes
des bois et donc simplifier le paysage
[Musique]
face à un paysage qui laissent de plus
en plus place à des lieux 100 caractères
l'état français réagit depuis plus de 30
ans le pays s'est doté de certaines
politiques paysagère mais surtout
d'atlas de paysages qui ont permis de
bien caractériser le territoire et ses
paysages
ce travail-là duré dix ans pour couvrir
l'intégralité de du territoire français
et il a permis deux d'affirmer qu' on
avait une diversité de paysages qui
était absolument extraordinaires ou
traverser la france du nord au sud ou
d'est en ouest
tous les 6 km vous changez vous changer
de configuration de physionomie
paysagère qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette
diversité de cette richesse et éviter
notamment qu'on banalise ça parce qu'on
sait très bien que les agriculteurs
seront moins nombreux pour le chercheur
leur ans lily si cette diversité dans le
paysage est l'un des fondements qui
caractérisent la culture française elle
offre aussi plus de résilience par
exemple face au changement climatique
plus un paysage et divers plus il peut
s'adapter à des crises et on le voit
bien actuellement
c'est dans les territoires qui sont
diversifiées qu'on trouve le plus de
sources de revenus à la fois pour de
l'alimentation pour produire d
agriculture diversifiée
la vallée de la bruche a voulu retrouver
cette diversité paysagère
la région a été l'une des premières en
france à agir contre cette déprise
agricole et à mettre en place une
politique paysagère dans le but de
rouvrir les paysages c'est à dire de
remettre certains territoires en prairie
hubert tu veux continuer d'ouvrir ou
bien comment tu vois ça on a ainsi
expliqué divers acteurs locaux mis du
financement sur la table et engager des
agriculteurs à prendre part au projet et
on a ciblé les endroits ouvrir
l'opération de réouvrir ce fonds de
vallées là qui amène au village
l'objectif est de redonner des espaces
ouverts
un agriculteur comme michael rochelle
profite ainsi de certaines portions de
terrain pour ses troupeaux il contribue
aussi à entretenir le paysage pour le
bien-être de tous
ça permet de créer déjà pour les gens
qui habitent au village un milieu de vie
qui agréable c'est quand même plus
agréable de vivre dans un endroit où le
soleil passe plus facilement ou mousse
et des prairies verdoyantes que de vivre
aux abords de la forêt où ça reste
humide où le soleil ne passe pas quoi ça
crée du lien social
certains affichent dans les villages en
dix ans depuis qu'on a réouvert nos
fonds de vallées entre deux communes eh
ben on se parle parce qu'on se voit tout
simplement
aujourd'hui le paysage de la vallée de
la bruche est un peu plus ouvert
qu'avant avec plus de prairies le nombre
d'agriculteurs a doublé en 30 ans c'est
donc dire que pour réussir un tel projet
il faut y mettre le temps
ce travail là il s'est fait sur un bâton
quasiment de 25 ans 30 ans et il était
possible parce qu'il ya un engagement
politique l'on regarde quand même le
point de vue qu'on a on n'a pas regardé
la carte postale de 1970 et on a dit on
veut ça c'était plus possible puisque
c'était un mode de vie bien particulier
par contre ce paysage d'aujourd'hui ou
correspond à une agriculture
d'aujourd'hui à des attentes
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à la société
le succès de ce travail a été soulignée
par tous à l'échelle française dont dans
la chaîne des puys aujourd'hui à la base
de certains volcans les pâturages
réapparaissent
on a de la chance d'avoir à notre
disposition environ 500 hectares à faire
pâturer nous mettons en commun de mines
mi-temps sur la chaîne des puys
on est quand même fier de pouvoir voir
la cime de nos montagnes de on peut pas
s'imaginer si on n'était pas là tout va
ce reboisement aurait aucun intérêt
après
et pour personne en 2018 la chaîne des
puys a été inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
le site des volcans est protégé mais
sous une nouvelle forme
une protection naturelle mais habitait
avec son agriculture
cette espèce de deux choses absolument
impensable naturel est habitée c'est ce
que la terre est devenue avec 7 milliard
d'habitants il n'y a pas d'endroits au
monde où il n'ya pas quelqu'un qui passe
est ce quelqu'un qui passe ou qui
habitent ou qu'ils utilisent
il est partie prenante de cette terre le
paysage de france attire par sa beauté
mais ce paysage peut devenir un risque
si on le tient pour acquis aujourd'hui
on n'a pas les moyens d'entretenir
toutes les surfaces qui étaient
entretenues quand vous aviez beaucoup
plus d'agriculteurs il ya un siècle donc
il faut s'adapter à ça si on veut un
paysage de qualité diversifiée il faut
le reconnaître en tous les cas que les
agriculteurs sont des jardiniers de du
paysage et surtout que l'entretien soit
rémunéré
[Musique]
ce que nous dit le paysage c'est quand
on regarde un petit carré d'herbe comme
celui-là ce petit carré d'herbe là il
est connecté au monde entier par les
politiques par les prix
et donc quand on va changer une
politique quand on va changer les prix
quand on va changer un accord commercial
on va changer l'apparence de cette
petite parcelle
et quand vous multipliez toutes les
parcelles ben vous changer le paysage de
comprendre ça nous permet aussi de faire
mieux la politique
de toute façon le paysage est un choix
et quand on ne choisit pas il n'en
arrive un autre
[Musique]